hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the monday morning
podcast for monday august 17th
2020 what's going on how are you
how you doing how's it going the world
is opening up man
i got the [ __ ] playoffs i got the
hockey playoffs on in the background
st louis blues in the vancouver canucks
going into overtime over time i've been
watching
all the [ __ ] hockey i possibly can
watch with two kids
under the age of four uh obviously
watching my boston bruins
uh great victory over carolina
fun series so far there two one
um tuka rosk man that was like the big
thing he was just like yes
he's boring and blah blah blah it's not
real hockey and
that type of stuff then i found out it's
his wife was pregnant he wanted to spend
time
with i get it man come on you know what
are you gonna do
you know [ __ ] play hockey you know
and then uh with no crowd
during a [ __ ] pandemic you got a kid
coming
you know i don't know whatever he helped
win us a cup i'm good with that guy he
comes back i got no [ __ ] problem with
it i'm sure
there's going to be some hot heads out
there but there's always hot heads
there's always people flipping out jesus
christ is that
what the [ __ ] is that guy's name elias
peterson is the whitest dude i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life
jesus christ
um hitler wouldn't even believe that
there could be somebody that
what white [ __ ] um and by the way i got
to tell you something
uh these [ __ ] dudes in the nhl were
obviously
still practicing because some of the
goals that i have seen
like i know i grew up watching some
great players but the [ __ ] level of
sniper that it seems like the average
player is
i mean there's barely the goaltender
barely any space and they're just
top corner [ __ ] left and right but
right you know between the body and the
arm god forbid
they got to go east west with their
[ __ ] arms like they're trying to like
they jumped off a [ __ ]
i don't know one of those gymnasts when
they jump up in the air and they get
their body together
so they can do the little spin around
thing sorry that was one of those
examples where i didn't know the name of
anything i was trying to describe it
really just went off the rails
but i've enjoyed uh the calgary flame
series has been a great one there's a
couple of really good matchups where you
got like the
uh you know the finesse team playing the
physical team so calgary being physical
dallas being more of the uh
you know the goal scoring team and i
love when the goal scoring team starts
pushing back you know
as a [ __ ] you know a little kid was
born with orange hair you know you're
definitely there's always the
the more physical teams going to win and
you live vicariously through
you know dallas stars have had enough
getting bullied by the calgary flames
they started pushing back in this
uh this last game lucicha's line is on
fire former [ __ ] boston bruins so i
love watching him playing well
um he looks like he's having a great
time out there who else is going on the
old [ __ ] creamsicles got the
number one in the [ __ ] east got their
goddamn orange and white dicks stepped
on the other day
five to nothing last i saw and then they
came back and they beat the hated habs
that's just an enjoyable series either
way just watching them both [ __ ]
you know i don't know somebody's gonna
lose either way that's gonna be fun
not like i really hate the flyers it's
just i don't know you know philly fans
they always [ __ ]
any sort of daylight they start running
their yaps like they've won something i
don't know i don't know what their deal
is but
um who else who else have i been why i
basically have been watching
i haven't seen much of the flyers uh
canadian series but
and i haven't seen any of avalanche
coyotes but other than that i pretty
much watched everything
uh and i've been watching it with my son
you know i'm trying not to do any tv
time but if he's looking at the tv
and his playoff hockey on i mean i gotta
let him do it right
um he by the way is awesome man like
he i already can tell is super super
smart like his sister
he's got this way of crying and then he
looks at you like
like really like he's he's like
like how do you not understand what i'm
trying to tell you and it's like really
making me
listen to him and being like oh you want
me to
shift you over is that i need to burp
cry need your
diaper changed you know and uh
i somewhere in like the last week of
watching playoff
hockey because what i do is i have that
little horseshoe pillow and i sit on one
of those exercise balls and i just
bounce it up and down with them that
keeps him happy right
and i don't know what happened because
he's given like he loves
his mom loves her absolutely loves her
cannot cannot get enough of her me he's
just kind of looking at me like
he just kind of eyebrows and move like
who the [ __ ] is this guy
[Laughter]
so um in like the last i don't know i've
probably watched like five hours of
hockey
in the last couple of days i swear to
god and i've just had him
you know take it whenever i have a shift
because the games have been on all day
long which has been [ __ ] great
so uh we've just been hanging out and
i've caught him i caught him like during
the second day just looking up at me
and i looked down at him and he gave me
this big smile
and now it's just like and then that was
it we just bonded he was just like all
right i like this guy this guy's cool he
bounces up and down i go to sleep
i wake up he's still there he's still
smiling he changes my diaper this guy's
cool he's not the smartest guy
takes him a minute for him to figure out
what i'm trying to tell him but he it's
it's been like a really uh
cool thing i kind of forgot you know
like the baby just immediately bonds
with the mom with the breastfeeding and
all that and then the dad you just sort
of like
you know you're sort of an extra
you know you're a reoccurring player uh
like on a sitcom or some [ __ ] there's
that [ __ ] [ __ ] in the blues
oh some of these blues i just look at
that i respect them they want a cup and
everything but jesus christ
look at their faces i'm just like oh my
god why did we trade away all our tough
guys
if any team needs to get [ __ ] punched
in the face it's this team and i'm
really fascinated by this series right
now because it's
uh vancouver's up 2-zip
two games to none just like the bruins
were
and i'm just gonna you know they've
gotten a little more rough in this game
i'm assuming
um i missed the i saw the first period
no i'm sorry i saw right in the second
period when uh vancouver scored
so we shall see what happens and i um
you know i had put my
lovely daughter to bed and all that
stuff and in the last two nights i went
out and i did my first two stand-up
spots
since this [ __ ] thing all started i
did a show uh
the people in the belly room you know
the comedy store put together a show
at the uh at the in the parking lot of
the magic
castle right here in hollywood
and uh i did a show last night oh my god
and i had not
you know i haven't done my accents like
march 10th
so and i'm trying to think like what the
[ __ ] am i going to talk about i have no
idea
you know started listening my act i had
one bad recording of it and
it was one of those nights where i was
just [ __ ] riffing and [ __ ] so
it really wasn't my act so i go up on
stage it's like this wooden
thing that they put together some
christmas lights on it and [ __ ] and
everybody's in their cars
and they got these little clacker things
that sound like [ __ ] locusts
which were really [ __ ] annoying the
first night
you know because it was just weird like
what is this sounds like jazz
snapping fingers or some [ __ ] they come
in some beatnik coffee house
in the village back in the 60s you know
when stand-up was first getting going
right
as far as like after the borch belt guys
getting going right so
um i go up on stage and i'm sort of you
know
i get the initial laughs what the [ __ ]
am i doing in a parking lot you know
[ __ ]
trying to get my feet underneath me just
trying to see if anything comes to me
so um nothing was coming to me so i just
you know i just went to my old tried and
true you know i just started trashing
women
that's just not what i want to do i want
to get away from that
so i start doing this bit
about women you know who's smarter and
that type of [ __ ] and
you know you know it starts going down
that road right and uh
so i do what i use do i butter up the
women to get them all [ __ ] going and
then i [ __ ] hit him with the overhand
left right
so i do that and all of a sudden this
woman i swear to god
sticks her head out her [ __ ] car
window like ace ventura
just starts yelling up at the sta i can
barely see her because people got their
headlights on and [ __ ] she's just going
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and she won't stop
through the whole bit right so i'm like
oh yeah
you must been on the debating team what
i'm just breaking the balls or whatever
and then i hear this guy voice go yeah
[ __ ] you buddy starts doing that i go
wait a minute i go are you with her
he's like i go take your [ __ ] balls
out of her
out of her purse before she bends you
over the sink when you get home tonight
right
you know the usual the usual sunshine
that i bring
so uh i continue with the joke and i
swear to god
the car backed up and they drove away
and two other cars drove away too and
i'm sitting there thinking to myself
like
as they're doing it like i'm in my head
going my first thought was like
i know i'm on last have i gone over i
feel like i just got up here
are they gonna get in trouble that was
my first thought and then i realized i
was like
and i said to the people i was like are
they leaving
and they're like yeah they're flicking
their lights and shits and i was just uh
one of the few times in my comedy career
and like i don't know a long time i was
just like speechless
i just i i really thought or i guess i
was hoping
that this white woman [ __ ]
act was gonna be done
and we could actually get to the truly
oppressed people
people of color that started the woke
movement but nope they picked right up
where they left off
and um you know i finished my set i
didn't have a i really did not have a
good set
and also in defense of the people who
drove away
is like a lot of my [ __ ] is sort of i
lead you down one way and then i
you know make you think one thing and
then i say something you know it's it's
a joke you can't know where it's going
so
but there's a rhythm to it and you have
to know what comes next once you piss
him off and i was
trying to remember it i was searching so
it was [ __ ] up the timing so they got
pissed but to drive away
it's like really like how [ __ ] old
are you
so i came home
after the set and i just was like
i was like depressed where i was just
like
all right i get it i'm the older comic
now and i get that younger people
aren't gonna understand me but like it's
not that they
don't understand you it's that they're
getting offended like it's like they're
acting like
they're old and you're some young punk
up there like
[ __ ] shooting heroin into your arm
and all i'm doing is telling a [ __ ]
joke so it was really
like depressing and just you know just a
lot of this [ __ ] that's been going on on
twitter watching
[ __ ] the ignorance
of comedians on social media like
attacking other comedians
um you know over [ __ ] that
nobody involved in the argument was even
there
so i don't really know what is going on
but it's just like guys
like you're literally playing into the
hands of people that are trying to
censor us
they've they've divided us and now it's
like you don't trash other [ __ ]
comics
you can get their phone number you gotta
[ __ ] beef with them have it out with
them right
i mean admittedly i've made fun of a few
comedians tweets but like i i'm not
trying to end their [ __ ] career
um so anyway uh
just that whole [ __ ] thing where it's
just like this ever since this whole
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like it's just gone so far
beyond
what it was supposed to be about and
this stuff is just literally it's like
not
fun anymore it used to be fun like to
to you know go
up there and just have thoughts and just
say them
and just have a good time and everybody
knew you were just [ __ ] around and it
was fun to watch other comics catch a
zone
and to see these moments and [ __ ] happen
you know people heckled you got it in
into it with people but there wasn't
like
this whole like political [ __ ]
politicized like
uh we need to end your career now
because of this joke
vibe that is like
it's literally undoing in a way
like you know people went to jail so you
could go up and do what you're doing and
now
um so-called open-minded people are like
undoing it it's [ __ ] it's really
bizarre
so i came home right and i don't have
any
like cigars in the house i don't drink
anymore i'm not a [ __ ]
drug user you know so
i mean as far as like illegal ones you
know so i [ __ ] uh
i came home like some sad person on prom
night and i i [ __ ] made a frozen
pizza
that sucked i ate the whole thing and
had a [ __ ] root beer
i woke up to the morning and it felt
like [ __ ]
and uh josh adam myers asked me because
you're coming down again tonight
and i was just like yeah i'm coming down
i'm going to come back i got to go back
down i can't end on that one
and i already talked to another buddy of
mine who's actually kind of stopped
doing stand-up
he's just like i just don't want to deal
with live crowds i want to write scripts
i just don't i don't want to deal with
live crowds anymore i mean this is
literally conversations like people are
having it's [ __ ] crazy so
i say [ __ ] it let me get back on the
horse so tonight i went down there and
actually found
a a recording for my act
in december and a lot of it was
holiday [ __ ] so it didn't quite work but
just to listen to my act a little i
listened to it
and i was like all right so i kind of
know what i'm going to start with and i
went up there and tonight
i [ __ ] killed and i had a great set
and i was used to the clacking
thing and i just did two sets in two
nights and i feel like i'm a [ __ ]
hundred feet tall i was making people
laugh i was fun i was silly
like last night i think i was just a
little walled off and just what i was
saying was bad and i got into it with
that chick in the car
and i just i don't think that's not what
i want to do
i don't want to make people leave the
show i don't mind pissing you off but i
mean in the end
you know i bring it around and make you
laugh but i just i [ __ ] hate doing
that
um so um
i ended up having a [ __ ] great set
tonight
and uh so i came home and i wasn't gonna
do my podcast tonight
and i come home and you know my poor
wife had to listen to me bitching last
night
so i came home i was like i [ __ ]
crushed i had a great set i'm psyched i
go i'm so psyched i don't
i don't want to do my podcast you know i
had such a great set it's like i don't
want to [ __ ] i want to [ __ ] it up
i want to sit down and eat a bowl of
cereal and hang out with you
and she's just like oh i thought you
were going to do your podcast
and i was like do you like not like me
anymore or whatever
she goes nah i'm just sort of you know
hanging out i was gonna watch my show
it's like oh i get it i get it you're
watching a real housewife show and if i
come in here i'm gonna ruin it i get it
i get it all right i'll leave so
poor thing she tries to watch her shows
and i never shut the [ __ ] up i mean
she leaves me alone when i watch my
stupid [ __ ] hockey and stuff so
it's only fair so now i'm out here i'm
doing this [ __ ] so
um i want to thank everybody for [ __ ]
who built the goddamn stage out there
and all of that [ __ ]
um yeah look at that
look at that i just got a text from
[ __ ]
marsh adam jayas josh adam myers he goes
you [ __ ] ripped it tonight i have not
gotten that text
in forever i want to thank tammy joe for
uh setting the whole thing up she runs
the belly room on a lot of you know some
of the nights when
back when you could do stand-up in a
comedy club they set that all up i know
there's a lot of hard work involved
they made sure everybody was safe and uh
like i was you know
i was not in a like i don't when you got
kids they put you in a good mood
um but uh
you know professionally was not in a
good mood so uh
i was definitely missing doing it and i
swear to god if they had that [ __ ]
thing
seven nights a week i would go down
there every [ __ ] night
that's that's how much i miss it so i
want to thank everybody too for showing
up sitting in your [ __ ] cars i hope
it made you laugh
uh i mean it's just
it's the greatest like [ __ ] i got a
new baby boy i got a beautiful daughter
i did two sets tonight in this [ __ ]
hockey playoffs i mean i'm in the best
mood ever
um so
anyways and speaking just like my my
life couldn't get any better i've been
basically fixing up my little office man
cave
uh thing here and i gotta give a couple
of shout outs here one to dean del rey
who has all these hookups uh i want to
he hooked me up with these speakers
he found me this like this vince vintage
[ __ ] am fm stereo receiver
for my record player um
my turntable to make it sound better and
uh i was listening to some zeppelin and
ac dc on this thing and he hooked me up
the the guys i should say that he
reached out to and they totally hooked
me up
uh klipsch k-l-i-p-s-c-h
speakers these [ __ ] things are
the [ __ ] i mean i can't even turn this
thing up
a quarter of the way and they these
things are like they
they've been making them like handmade
since forever and they look like they're
right out of the 70s
i'm telling you something don cheadle's
character would have sold in boogie
nights
things are the [ __ ] and i got to
rearrange some stuff so i can figure out
uh where i can put them and um
you know i think late night i'm gonna
come out here i'm gonna watch a little
hockey playoffs
you know and i'm gonna crank some
[ __ ] tunes
it's just like it's i don't know just
little things like this
music hockey making people laugh
it's just [ __ ] awesome man and it's
really great considering
all the [ __ ] that you know it's
another thing too my buddy passing away
um which by the way we're gonna do the
sickest [ __ ]
you know celebration and memorial show
for the great wayne brevity when um
when uh when all this [ __ ] is over
now i'm not doing it with everybody
sitting in [ __ ] cars
uh we're gonna figure out where we're
gonna do it and all the guys i'm gonna
try to get as many guys from our
graduating class
of comics um
everybody that knew him and loved him
man we're gonna do a [ __ ]
it's gonna be a killer [ __ ] show
there's gonna be drinking there's gonna
be pizza the only thing that's gonna be
missing is hanging out at [ __ ]
dominic's
who's from boston and remember dominic's
it's right across from uh the wilbur
dominic's pizza that [ __ ] great bar
you know they had like you know all the
the [ __ ]
the bar flies up at the bar then they
had like the little dance floor area
and then they just had the giant slice
of pizza too
you know something that's a shame that
dave portnoy
bar stool sports can't do a review of
that one it no longer exists because
um one of the things he says the bigger
the slices are usually
poorer quality which is so [ __ ] true
but that was not true with dominic's
dude it was
it was an incredible what it was was a
great pizza and it was just
a ridiculously generous slice that they
always gave you
so um i don't know look at him oh billy
good news huh extra extra read all about
it all freckles is in a great [ __ ]
mood
um yeah but it's really bumming me out i
can't go to the funeral though i mean i
just got kids and [ __ ]
i just can't do it can't risk that and
we need too much help and then i have to
come back and quarantine for [ __ ] 14
days
um so but all that's gonna do is just
make me
make this night for him even bigger
and uh he's just such a [ __ ] great
guy that everybody i talked to was like
dude i am [ __ ] in
i am there or whatever i just have to
figure out with everybody's schedule
how to make it happen um probably do it
on like a monday or a tuesday
night and um you know make sure the west
coast guys can get back there
and then i know all the east coast guys
are gonna show up so
um you know what's funny dude you wanna
hear something crazy
like almost like cinematic so whenever i
would go out
whenever i would head out with wayne
right i always you know vinnie age that
was his nickname right
because he was hey how you doing which
became age right
uh and he was half italian so we call
him vinnie age right so he'd pick up the
phone i'd be like
vinnie age and he like billy red what do
you say what do you do
that's how it always started then we go
out
to a spot and then start drinking or
whatever and then we would always end up
nine times out of ten we would end up
with this jack-in-the-box
on coanga and sunset and
uh and i would always get the ultimate
cheeseburger with ketchup i forget if i
told this story and then i get the
friend now we never understood why their
ultimate cheeseburger doesn't have
ketchup on it i don't know why
it's a great first fast food burger it's
[ __ ] great but they didn't have
ketchup and i needed ketchup right so i
get that and i get the fries and
um i forget what he would always order
but i was reading this other comic that
i started with dave mclaughlin said he'd
always get the number six so he'd get
the number six and then he'd always get
the two tacos
and i'd always think like dude you get
tacos that [ __ ] jack-in-the-box he'd
be like oh dude they're [ __ ] good you
gotta get the tacos right
and i always just for some reason
pictured them like you know those hot
dogs at 7
11. i just pictured like these tacos
sitting under these lights like because
like to me it's like jack-in-the-box is
a burger place
and uh now they're trying to get cute
and do a little [ __ ]
taco [ __ ] on the side like if i you
know if i want a taco i'm gonna go to a
[ __ ] taco truck or
taco stand right so
anyway i was driving around and uh
because i was supposed to do a spot at
the store friday night
they had this way that they were working
this thing out where it was like
you know in in the or the original room
um when you're standing on stage just to
the crowd's left the performer's right
it's this big window
and that looks out onto the patio so
they were doing shows
i guess where you would the comic now
stands behind the window
which by the way has autographs on it
you're looking through the autographs
and then the crowd sits in the on the on
the patio
you know but i guess whatever they got
shut down because of some
some [ __ ] i don't know what happened
right oh running the goaltender oh my
god
what the [ __ ] just happened vancouver
runs to saint louis blues
back up goaltender allen who's that
beruby who's that [ __ ] coach
what is he gonna [ __ ] come on man you
[ __ ] love that type of play
that was your whole career i respect it
too um
i think he lost an edge though what the
[ __ ] happened
yeah he just lost a [ __ ] edge oh and
he went right into the [ __ ]
used to be called the post the crossbar
in the post when i was a kid
[Music]
um and that [ __ ] bennington dude
whoever
whoever the whatever his [ __ ] name is
that guy
they they took him out this is their
backup call he's all right
he's all right he's all right so anyway
so i'm driving around you know my spot
got cancelled i'm feeling sad and [ __ ]
so
i'm like you know what i call up my wife
i'm like you know what i'm you want
anything i'm going to jack in the box so
i tell her the whole story why
and i'm going to go and i'm going to get
the ultimate cheeseburger with ketchup
and fries i'm going to get those for
myself and then
uh is a tribute a tip of the cap to my
uh
now passed away friend the great late
great wayne previtty
i'm going to get these two [ __ ] tacos
and see what this shit's all about right
so i pull up to the jack in the box it's
like a movie
my friend is gone i'm going to jack in
the box as a tribute right to get the
two tacos with my order and i pull up
and the jack-in-the-box
is gone and i'm like really i mean
that's one of those universe things
that's like dude i get it my friend's
gone but yeah i can't do this here
and evidently it's been closed for a
while and wayne
actually heard about it because he used
to go there with this other dude dave
mclaughlin right
um and they actually like that was like
their spa
like this is just where we ended up
right
and uh i guess they're they're putting
up some 21 story
art deco themed hotel there with a pool
on top parking underneath and uh
you know it's just one of those things
uh you know that you know that
expression you can never go home i never
understood that like what i can [ __ ]
go home but it just means you
you can go back but it's not going to be
the same
um by the way i think the blues are on a
power play
i love that guy was bitching about the
tripping it's like you [ __ ] tripped
them
you know i mean they really nhl reps do
a really good job i feel about putting
away their whistles in overtime like you
you almost have to [ __ ] you just got to
do something really blatantly obvious
um but this is so [ __ ] huge such a
fascinating series
to watch because i watched the bruins
last year and and the way how physical
the blues
play it's like you don't want to get
dragged into the deep water
you got to beat these guys in in six or
fewer games
so i feel like this is a must win for
vancouver
um i'm calling it right now if [ __ ]
uh if [ __ ]
whoever wins tonight wins this series
that's what i'm saying
um although they don't seem like they're
playing as physical this year who knows
i have no what the
why are you listening to me give [ __ ]
hockey analysis i can barely skate
all right let's do some other reads here
indochito
indochino uh having clothes that
fit just right can be a huge confidence
booster how phallic was that first thing
huh
clothes that fit right right and snug
around your [ __ ] junk
the lady can see which way your [ __ ]
schmeckle's hanging
uh describe any particular issue you run
into when shopping for clothing
i [ __ ] hate it i hate the whole
[ __ ] process i gotta go in there and
i gotta
wander through all these clothes that
are made for young people and
you know i gotta try to pick something
where i still look
sort of in style but not like i'm trying
to look young um i'm sorry says wishing
sleeves were a little bit longer
being a smedium etc
you know what i hate i hate buying belts
they're either too [ __ ] big or too
goddamn small how about that
all right indochino was started on the
belief that custom clothing shouldn't
cost a fortune
talk about the convenience of having
clothing that fits perfectly at a right
price
yeah that would be really convenient you
know what i like too is if you have it
custom fitted
all right now it's going to keep you in
shape
because that [ __ ] fits perfectly and
then if you know if you come home and
eat a frozen pizza like i did last night
all of a sudden you're
uh you know you know right where you
tuck your shirt in all of a sudden you
know you're just in that little
triangle shows you know where it starts
to split the shirt tails right down
there yeah you don't want that that's
not a good look
a little happy trail sticking out
there's a [ __ ] picture
uh within the cheeto uh you can get
made to measure clothing at fair prices
including suits blazers shirts and coats
you get to customize everything from the
fabric and the lining to the lapel
shape and monogram the choice is all
yours your clothing is then made to your
exact measurements so it fits you
perfectly
uh the best part is indochino suits
start at just 299
uh all customize all customizations
included
uh indochino has showrooms across north
america or you can book a virtual
appointment and shop online at
indochino.com
and right now you can get an extra 30
bucks off
any purchase i love 30. who picks 30.
that's a great [ __ ] original number
five dollars off ten dollars off you
know
30 bucks i like that off any purchase of
or more at indochino.com when entering
burr at checkout b-u-r-r that's
indochino.com promo code burr
all right who do we got next here uh
policy
genius uh you know with everything going
on right now
a lot of people are asking if it's even
possible to buy
life insurance at all um yeah that's a
great question well
uh the answer is yes with an exclamation
point
i'm trying to read this copy and look at
every shot there's two [ __ ] saves
right there on the blues
uh the answer is yes it's still easy to
shop for life insurance right now
and if you have loved ones depending on
your income you probably should
right now you could save up to 1500 or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policy
this is [ __ ] great because i went out
and got life insurance not using policy
genius
and it was an absolute nightmare all
right there's
50 million things you got to take and
this is like you know
it's like you don't want to do it this
is like valet parking of getting uh
life insurance um right now you can say
or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade for a decade or
more
those savings really start to add up
what is policy genius it's an insurance
marketplace built and backed by a team
of industry experts here's how it works
step one
head to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price step two
apply for your lowest price step three
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape policy genius
works for you
not the insurance company so if you hit
any speed bumps
during the application process they'll
take care of everything dude it is such
a [ __ ] headache
trying to get life insurance so to have
somebody go out and
not only handle the red tape but
actually get you the best price
i'm telling you this this is something
that i wish i i
i used when i did this uh that anyways
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating
across 1600 reviews uh and
across over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
and google
so if you need life insurance head to
policy genius.com right now to get
started
you could say 1500 or more by comparing
quotes
on their marketplace policy genius uh
when it comes to insurance it's nice
to get it right yeah i'm telling you if
you got you got a wife
you got kids you got a wife and kids you
got a life partner whatever whatever it
is you got to make sure they're going to
be all right all they should be dealing
with when you die is the grief of you
not being there
don't don't send them to the poor house
huh
anyway me undies oh look who's here
me undies me undies watching all the
[ __ ] hockey
doo doo doo me undies be undies do you
like that asian snack called pocky
it's got a little tuna and some crunchy
[ __ ]
get some [ __ ] underwear
up against her [ __ ] it's nice and soft
with the [ __ ] model
[Music]
boop all right me undies me undies wants
to talk about your underwear
um like seriously they have a lot of
feelings about it and want to chat with
anyone who will listen so here goes my
undies just
wants to feel wants everyone to feel
comfy as heck
with the freedom to express themselves
oh the blue
scored oh my god
vancouver is in trouble
oh my god you got to put these guys uh
look at them look at them they've all
been there they all been there they know
they know what's going to happen just
like that isn't that [ __ ] amazing
just like that the whole [ __ ] series
just turned around
it just [ __ ] turned around and these
[ __ ] these [ __ ] vancouver
canucks who've never won a goddamn
cup it's bad enough they're a canadian
team that's never won a cup they're also
called the canucks
so they're like canadian times two
canadians squared i didn't see what
happened
it looked like it was even strength
somehow they got caught up ice or was
that a [ __ ]
jesus that guy was so in alone it looked
like a [ __ ] penalty shot
wow
that's huge [ __ ] huge
but i'll tell you what it's not as huge
as the [ __ ] softness up against your
balls of me undies look at that look at
that
look at that [ __ ] segway uh they make
the world's soft
world's softest undies in classic colors
and fun prints like
dinos and surfboards i was just reading
about dino uh ferrari
today enzo ferrari's uh
son who unfortunately died of ms
incredible movie waiting to be made
about enzo ferrari anyway
uh is your underwear drawer something to
be proud of or a little embarrassed by
how much more fun would it be to get
dressed every day if you knew you got to
pick from
a drawer full of fun in adorable undie
prints like
orcas bees or cherries my undies is
serious about
softness no like so
no like so serious they scoured the
world for the softest fabric
known to man it all starts with the
sustainably sourced
beechwood trees that magically turn from
pulp to yarn
to undies undies that kind of feel like
heaven on your skin is it amazing what
human beings figure out how to do
who turns a tree into [ __ ] underwear
uh you know who did adam
he did it first made some [ __ ] me
undies for eaves and what did she do
huh what did that [ __ ] goddamn idiot
what does she do
after all her yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
she goes right down and [ __ ]
bites the apple for comfort from the
outside
literally to in keep your undies drawers
stocked with me undies the me undies
membership a subscription that sends new
pairs right to your door plus get
site-wide savings and exclusive sales
miani's has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
you get 15 off and free shipping
this is a no-brainer especially because
they have 100 satisfaction guarantee
to get your 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guarantee
go to
meundies.com that's meundies
m-e-u-n-d-i-e-s
dot com slash burr b-u-r-r i got one
more here stamps.com
going back take semi-way back
stamps.com back where it all started um
as we slowly adjust to the new normal
we still need to be smart about how we
do business luckily there's a stamps
there's stamps.com to make things easier
they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office all from their own
computers
with stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and avoid going to the post
office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
and no residential surcharges you've
heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now and if you haven't
tried it
what are you waiting for stamps.coms
bring stamps.com brings all the mailings
and shipping services you need right to
your computer
in the comfort of your own home or
office whether you're a small business
sending invoices
and online seller shipping out products
or just working from home and need to
mail stuff stamps.com can handle it all
with each
simply use your computer to print
official us
postage 24 7 for any letter any package
any class of mail
anywhere uh you you uh you want to send
sorry and like i said with stamps.com
you get great discounts too
five cents off every stamp and up to 62
percent off u.s postal services and ups
shipping rates stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you
time and money right now my listeners
can get a special offer that includes
a four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
and type in bur b-u-r-r that stamps
dot-com
enter burr all right there we go
um hey let's talk drums here for a
second right
i was watching this nico mcbrain like
drum clinic
and he's showing all of this cool [ __ ]
and i don't know who the
[ __ ] shot this thing but i swear to god
i i want to say it was whoever directed
water world
with kevin costner you know those epic
[ __ ] shots they had where they were
like
he'd be sailing one way and like the
camera be going the other way they were
doing that
while he was playing drums just going
over and going back out into the crowd
and it's just like
i got it buddy you have a jib camera
he's playing where eagles dare i'm
trying to see his foot technique
there's no there's nothing on the to
show what his foot looks like
and you're hovering over the top of it
like uh
i don't know like he's playing a ballad
why am i out in the crowd
i want to see how he does it man all
right um
so anyway i had uh i got busy and i got
depressed last week
with wayne dying so i kind of laid off
the drums it just
wasn't what i wanted to do so as i was
telling you i was creeping closer
to the good times bad times stuff you
know the triplet
lick i was up to 85 bpms i was within 10
bpms i played it [ __ ] i got three in
a row at 90. i was right
[ __ ] there right oh look at ray bork
he still looks great
he still looks [ __ ] great um what a
head of hair man god bless him good for
him
um anyway i uh
so i came back you know
yesterday and i sat down and
it's [ __ ] hilarious i was thinking
like i wonder if i can still play it at
85 bpms
and just that thought alone
all of a sudden i couldn't even do it at
75 bpms
but i've been doing this learning you
know through davey glitch and all that
[ __ ]
to how to like relax in a good way it's
just like doing comedy last night i was
tight i had a bad set
i got to do it some lady drove away in a
little camry right
and you know that's not what i wanted
tonight i was relaxed i didn't give a
[ __ ] i had a great time nobody left
from a prius to a [ __ ] you know truck
with a lift kit everybody had a good
time
so today i went down there i was just
like you know what i'm feeling [ __ ]
good i'm relaxed you know who gives a
f [ __ ] the goddamn metronome let me just
play this
have a good time and just look at this
like the gym you haven't been you didn't
go to the gym for the
for a week right you're not gonna be
able to bench as much as you could bench
so just go out there
but just get a workout in and i had a
good time and next thing you know i was
back up to 80 bpms couldn't do 85
but i was fine with it and um
i just you know when when it comes to
that part where he
uh where it's you gotta pull do the lick
like ten times in a row
i actually i don't know i i relax and i
smile
and i just think like let's see how many
i get and whenever i do that all of a
sudden i get them all
but when i start thinking yesterday i
did 85. i gotta i got to do at least 86
in it
then i can't even do it at 75 it's it's
[ __ ]
um oh jesus
who's here hang on a second
somebody knocking at my door
what are you doing here hello how's it
going i'm in the middle of recording
people
list this is an actual recording
come on stop making a mess all right you
didn't tell me you were coming out i
would have grabbed the other freaking
microphone and look who's here everybody
hey how's it going the lovely nia
so i thought i was sort of coming in
towards the end all right well if you
don't want to be on that's fine
people love you though well no it's not
that what are you doing what are you
talking about what's happening
i was talking about um trying to get
better at drums
and how in in comedy and last night i
had a bad set i was didn't remember my
ex i was a little tight didn't go
well people are driving away tonight i
didn't give a [ __ ] it went well and then
the same thing with drums if i think
i want to do better than i did the day
before you just
just that thought alone is enough to
somehow
mess with your internal self and you
don't play as well
yeah i was just talking about that oh
that's cool
i thought you came out here because you
wanted to talk about the amazing
documentary
that was recommended by one of my
listeners tread t-r-e-a-d
like don't tread on me on um netflix on
netflix
it's about i don't want to ruin it but
it's just it's just it happened in real
life you know it's so it's not exactly
like a spoiler alert but we don't have
this
well no we haven't kind of what we're
going to talk about yeah it was in the
news and stuff and you know oh my god
this movie
this is a movie documentary documentary
the first
20 or so minutes i kind of tuned out i
was like you know
this isn't really my um it's a white guy
of a certain age in the middle of
nowhere he went out and bought a little
piece of the american dream
yeah in a town that you would never go
to oh that i would never
they would never want me there they
would stare at me
like i was in a [ __ ] zoo if i went
there if you know what i mean
so but i have to say so it's this it's a
story about a man
who uh takes revenge
uh this town that he lives in this these
people in his town who are on his like
list his [ __ ] list basically
and he goes through in this big tricked
out
we got a back up here this guy
this [ __ ] guy this [ __ ] this
all he wants to do he wants to start
this business
and they go all right well you got to
hook up your business to the to the
sewer it's like 800 feet or something
like that it was all this money and he
wouldn't [ __ ] do it
and he gets into it with the town he
thought they were putting the squeeze on
him
he thought there was some reason he
thought it was a good old boy network
yeah he thought and that he was being he
was not included in it and he was
being sort of pushed out of it and he
felt very slighted
by the the men who were in charge of the
the big companies in this very very
small town
and this is what's amazing he owned a
muffler shop
and he was the greatest [ __ ] welder
and he could fix anything
the greatest [ __ ] welder he like that
is like an understatement like this man
was like who knew like
the the the skill and the absolute like
villainy that's what it is it's like
he's like a classic
like superhero villain okay so she's
alluding to what he ended up welding
together when he
goes to take revenge on this town so
basically
he gets into with these towns these
townspeople in this you know there's
this you know the big rich
family that's been there and and they're
claiming been there for like
ages and ages like generations and
generations right they kind of like own
the town
so when he decides that he's going to
take his revenge what i loved was he
gave him a chance
this guy goes out to california he buys
a [ __ ] bulldozer i forgot and he
has it shipped back and where his
muffler shop is is it's right across the
way from the the rich family that sits
on the board that he thinks is [ __ ]
with them
so he parks the bulldozer pointed
at his rivals business
and he has a for sale sign on it he
tried to help him out and they were into
heavy machinery
and this guy was religious and he was
just like you know he gave him an
opportunity to buy it
and they didn't buy it and according to
the recording was was then
obviously god wanted him to do what he
wanted to do
he also wanted to build a structure
across from him that was going to
produce a lot of like
waste and stuff like that and like
debris and things like that according to
him
and he would be right like downwind of
it or something so he just really felt
like they were out to get him like there
was all this like
bureaucratic nonsense red tape [ __ ] to
get his business up to code according to
what they decided
so he had just had enough and he made a
series of tapes
where he's just going on and on and on
kind of like a podcast
that no one listened to and
um until the end and then he [ __ ]
reeked wait long long story short
he brought this bulldozer inside
to his he shut down his muffler shop
this guy had a little bit of money
and for a [ __ ] year he worked on this
thing
for a year he made this [ __ ]
bulldozer he like it was like he
surrounded it
encased it in like make metal with
concrete you you couldn't shoot into
this thing this thing
was once it got going it wasn't gonna
stop it was completely bulletproof it
was completely like
fireproof it was like they like
he had like he had these cameras that he
so he could see where he was going
because you couldn't see him
and he had like this little like this
this pressurized air
to blow on it to get the debris off so
he gets in this [ __ ] thing drives
across the street and
bulldozes his rival's business he
doesn't stop there
he drives down the street cops on the
main drag the main drag of town
just like just it just aims for
all the rivals everybody who's shot on
the everyone who sat on the [ __ ]
board
he bulldozed all their businesses he was
shooting at the [ __ ] giant propane
[ __ ] gas natural gas for the town
thank god he didn't hit it
and what ended up happening these guys
jumped up on the tank they were like
there's there has got to be a way to
breathe
they threw some shot down into it or
some sort of
fire they tried to shoot down you just
could not stop this guy i think he was
like an evil genius
and what ended up happening was he ended
up like
listen you gotta yeah don't don't reveal
you guys i mean i said the whole [ __ ]
i know even though we talked about the
whole thing when you watch it
it's even crazier than how we're
describing it but like can i just say
that that movie that documentary spoke
to me
in such a way that i just did not
anticipate like
the catharsis of watching him
in this like that's what i mean he's
like a superhero he's an anti-hero
he was an auntie here it was like it was
like it was like a bad 80s action movie
that was real
he even had a catchphrase he just kept
saying they messed with the wrong guy
yeah that's an 80s it was it was awesome
yeah it was really really awesome and
just seeing him just go
and bulldoze these places it was just
like there's a scene in bridesmaids when
like kristen wiig's character is
freaking out at the um
the wedding show the bridal shower and
there's this kid watching her freak out
and destroy things and
she just keeps going so awesome so
awesome i was like that kid
watching it i just thought it was so
amazing that i probably thought it was
amazing because he didn't kill anybody
but like i just it was so
satisfying to watch him bulldoze into
these buildings and watch them crumble
all around him like you know when i felt
that
oh my god you know when i felt that i
lived vicariously through somebody was
when russell crowe
was in that hotel that time and he got
mad at the person downstairs
because they couldn't tell him how the
phone worked and he ripped the phone out
of the wall
and he went downstairs and he threw the
phone at the guy who couldn't help him
now i know you shouldn't do that but
like how awesome he must
immediately regret it but how awesome it
must have felt
to literally the thing that you
that they can't help you with to take
that thing like how many times you want
to take
i want to take my laptop i've never
wanted to do that but i just to go down
to the apple store
and just be like then work and just
frisbee it
into them i wouldn't do it slice their
heads with it
yeah right it was just it was just
awesome and then you know
just the white on white crime you know
what i mean it's just you love to see it
it's just well he was he was
international so
yeah he was international news and then
reagan died the next day and he totally
[ __ ] [ __ ] blocked him fell
out of the news cycle and like that's
the yes exactly and the ultimate like
the real
disrespect he thought he was
disrespected before
he was disrespected even more after he
died now of course it was a tragic thing
but like
you you have to watch it it's like if
you have
ever had a feeling of that you wanted to
take revenge on go easy
let's not inspire people to do something
no oh god no yeah i know right igniting
all the
incels and whatnot but let's get let's
get back to something a little lighter
other than
bulldozing everybody in your hometown
that you don't like
all right here we do that here we go my
girlfriend is guilting me
into going to medical school in russia
[Laughter]
she's trying to ship your ass off she's
trying to get rid of you
let me see here hey bill love your humor
you're an absolute riot thank you i am
in a real
conundrum this guy's smart huh conundrum
who uses that word
it really doesn't take a lot to impress
you
who in your world says conundrum it's
not that like
odd of an a word for people to use like
people use it be funny all the time use
it in a sentence just casually throw
that out there and just
wow me with it go ahead wow you with it
wow me with conundrum
i'm not gonna wow you with it i'm just
going to say well that's quite a
conundrum
that's all i got right now i'm not going
to wow you with it sorry
you know why that was a wow worthy word
which is
my point anyway just keep reading that
wasn't you
you wait you insulted me a little bit
there right yeah
you're trying to back your way out of
that i'm impressed by the word conundrum
there
i like it has drum in it almost sounds
like condominium
could have my drums in a condo not deal
with your [ __ ] pain in the ass you
know
sorry so my girl shot it
without me i lasted like 35 years
without you what are you talking about
so my girlfriend
couldn't go any further is my point he
doesn't get any better than this this is
what it's like with you constantly
interrupting me
all right so my girlfriend is russian
american uh her parents are from russia
her dad went to medical school there and
wants her to go to medical school there
too
when we first started dating the plan
was for her to always go to law school
which is super convenient because the
school is in the city where i live
all of this started to come into place
she got accepted to a great school
but now she's changing her mind about
law school
now she doesn't just want me to quit my
job she wants me
a guy with a communications degree who
barely graduated college
to go with her to medical school and
enroll as a student
wait is she you communal i have a
communication degree you're gonna make
it through medical school
[Laughter]
although he did use the word conundrum
wait am i the dumbest guy with a
communications degree this is horrific
um i love her but i told her no
many times and every time she guilts me
into telling her
i'll think about it well yeah she's
manipulating you don't do that
but then she hits me with the if you
love me
you wouldn't have to think about it
you'd move to russia and
go to medical school with me oh god no
how do you say go [ __ ] yourself in
russian
the biggest part that makes me
uncomfortable is that she said
her dad will pay for it all and i know
no dude you don't want some russian dude
paying for your education you're gonna
owe him something
this sounds like the beginning of like
some mob movie he's gonna expect him to
marry his daughter and be a doctor
and make a [ __ ] ton of money and have
babies and [ __ ] that's what he's gonna
do yeah well they're gonna bury you out
in the snow and they're never gonna find
you
the biggest part that makes me okay uh
[ __ ] that the biggest part that makes me
uncomfortable is that she said her dad
will pay for it
and i know any time someone does a favor
for you they'll always ask
something in return i do i do not want
to do this but i feel
like i am in too deep to back out of the
situation you are not
you are not the only way out is to fail
the entry exam on purpose
no that's the chicken [ __ ] way out
should i go through with it and risk my
job
savings should i go through with it and
risk my job
savings moving to russia or fail the
exam and break up with her
don't take the exam and break up with
her yeah i know come on now
come on now let's let's not be silly
you're not gonna actually take the
[ __ ] test
that's absurd you know i read a great
pablo escobar
quote about lying
he goes i never lie people who lie it's
because they're afraid and i'm never
afraid
and i was like wow he says when you lie
that means you're afraid
this guy is lying because he's afraid
he's afraid
of the whole [ __ ] situation this is a
great opportunity
for you to go pablo escobar here pablo
escobar that [ __ ]
that's right get your balls yes
you know back down in your sack where
they [ __ ] belong instead in your
throat
and just say listen i'm not doing this
and she goes well if you really love me
you would and i will evidently
i don't love you enough nostrovia
however the [ __ ] you say
cheers um
i don't know too much russia oh god yeah
um
how much russian do you know none okay
um all right spaceba or something like
that
it was on sex in the city never mind i
just remember nostrovia
what does that mean it just means cheers
i know any booze thing i know um would
you ever go to russia
would you ever go to moscow or something
uh yeah i would
i would love to go there i feel like
it's not a good idea for americans to go
to russia
well you know it's i think the people
like it's tense right now yeah it's
always kind of tense
but russian dudes are [ __ ] hilarious
they're great hockey players they're
tough as [ __ ] nails i mean there's a
lot to love about
russian people i feel like they [ __ ]
beat the germans all the way back to
their goddamn
[ __ ] strudel whatever the [ __ ] it is
they eat over there
um i know a russian girl and she is
lovely
i know a girl named karen and she's the
nicest person
stop calling white women karen and no
and she's very um
no she's really cool and she's like has
really good taste in music and she's
very sexy i think russian girls are sexy
i think that i like their accent
it's kind of harsh but it's very much
like you know
like they're in charge sorry where is
this going
i'm gonna bring her over sometime all
right man to man advice
i think i just set up a [ __ ]
threesome there man-to-man advice to an
18 year old
from the republic of georgia russian
girls hit me up in my dm's i'm just
kidding
please don't no don't do that because
those chicks are super smart
they're they're playing it like we're in
the varsity team i'm the jv team they're
on the varsity team they'll come up
so it wouldn't work all right okay
man-to-man advice to an 18 year old from
the republic of georgia which i believe
is in
like it's east of uh isn't that easter
greece in high school from the republic
of georgia
i have never hated how you started a
sentence
more ever in my life you've interrupted
me
nine times trying to get through this
[ __ ] thing
i'm trying to get the momentum of this
podcast
again again we had an
exchange tune you know you sounded like
joe piscopo back in the day when he
would do
alan font where we thought it would be
funny
if you did that on a first date we would
not be [ __ ] married
interrupt me with that long slow
speaking
who gives a [ __ ] oh my god
sorry people she she gave birth about
you know a couple months ago she's still
recovering she's breastfeeding she's
exhausted
you suddenly you're like 80 years old
and our favorite song
why don't you go download a shuffleboard
app
[ __ ] blue hair all right oh my god hi
why are you being so mean i'm trying to
because you've been annoying me you've
been annoyed you went
you you you got to get with the flow of
the show here you interrupted like nine
times
all right hey bill i need someone to
give me an advice and advice
i love this i need someone to give me an
advice oh wait it's time here we go here
we go
come on play it
it's time for advice hey
[Music]
i had some advice with an exchange
student
what is this oh [ __ ] it's more music
tonight
today i told someone that i don't want
to be
their friend ever
what ever even thought
wait okay i love this is broken english
hey bill i need someone to give an
advice because i don't feel
i have no one to talk to all right today
i told someone that i don't want to be
their friend
ever even thought we have mutual even
though
we have mutual friends i have been
hanging around this guy for quite some
time
and we've never got along especially
after he started calling me names and
being disrespectful to me well yeah this
is easy
[ __ ] this guy he's a bully uh we settled
after a little quarrel
uh but today he asked me if i changed my
mind about him and i told him no
jeez this guy's [ __ ] relentless uh my
friends did not
liked it and everyone told me that i was
wrong because he is our mutual friend
i don't give a give a damn what kind of
friend listen this guy's an [ __ ] and
your friends are [ __ ]
i don't give a damn about this guy but
i'm afraid my actual friends will stop
contacting me as i am leaving my country
to study abroad uh
these are the guys i grew up with i
don't want to end my time with them
on a bad note but i [ __ ] up because i
did not
said a lie and did not told that [ __ ]
that we were good all right help me out
here because
i did not say a lie
and did not because this is fun yeah
plus i've always had a problem with
contacting other men
as i grew up without a father and had no
one to mentor
me how to behave and what is right or
wrong i'm asking you
what would you have done in my place and
what should i do
should i have set a lie or the truth in
this situation what that you like this
guy no if this guy's being an [ __ ] to
you
[ __ ] this guy and if your friends if you
told your friends that he's been an
[ __ ] and they're still saying you
need to be friends with this guy then
your friends are [ __ ]
and studying abroad is a great way to go
get some new friends
p.s you got some fans in the republic of
georgia well i'm a fan of you for
[ __ ] listening god bless you that's
what that's my advice what do you say
let's say you yeah totally would you say
this is a bit of a conundrum
i would say that's a bit of a conundrum
but yeah i think it sounds like you need
a whole new set of friends
yeah i think you gotta go [ __ ] all you
guys
i'm leaving the republic of georgia to
go study abroad when i come back you
guys are all still gonna be here you're
all gonna be
you're all dead to me yeah you're all
gonna still be here
giving tours of [ __ ] transylvania and
i'm gonna be in [ __ ] medical school
um all right joke trouble with my lady
hey billy big brood yeah that's cool i
only got two i don't have a brood i
think you need at least three to have a
brood
uh congratulations on rounding off the
family with the sun i was talking about
how he's smiling now
big smiles he's so beautiful he's a
he's a good-looking dude i'm not gonna
lie to you
[Laughter]
and now you have the full set uh i love
the podcast
and it it especially kept me going
during
uh lockdown so thank you for keeping it
going me and my lady
just got engaged congratulations and
moved in together she's beautiful funny
clever and has a heart of gold
uh and she's black this is important
later
uh-oh here we go
um though the world don't move to the
beat it's just one drum
um so i love i love her to death but she
does
leave [ __ ] on the stairs all the time
shoes mostly
and i try to diffuse this with the joke
which went badly
and i wanted your opinion on what if
on if i'm doing what i'm doing wrong
okay so i trip over a pair of her shoes
as i'm coming down the stairs
and yelled up to her really 30 years
after
ghost dad and black people are still
leaving [ __ ] on the stairs
i don't get that joke i don't either i
never saw that movie
but okay oh you know what you went you
went to
obscure it went down like a wet fart
he said and the rest of the day was a
bit frosty
uh it is is it down to me being a white
guy
saying it or is it the cosby reference
that
makes it seem worse it's a double whammy
my friend
you not only try to hey have black
people doing this which is already here
yeah yeah it depends on how you guys
joke you had to throw in a yeah a cosby
reference oh
he said or is it just flat out not funny
if i'm no stand up but i
okay i'm no stand up but i thought at
least it
merited a courtesy laugh uh
best to you and your family keep doing
what you're doing i think he could have
got away with it if they have a playful
relationship like that but then he
you got to kind of say [ __ ] like that in
like a stupid accent
you'd if like if he went like uh what
what did he say
let me try to make this funny to you
yeah i know but the thing is i don't
know
really 30 years after ghost dad black
people still
see you laughing because it's [ __ ]
stupid because now it sounds like i'm
clearly joking
but if i went like really 30 years after
ghost dad and black people are still
leaving [ __ ] on the stairs and then it
doesn't work
yeah that's true that's true that's got
it you got to be silly
that's true just buy a nice bouquet of
flowers and say i'm sorry for my stupid
insensitive joke it won't happen again
and just just move on just player this
what is like
but what is that reference though i
never saw ghost dad that's the thing
people might have seen ghost dad more
than i thought but like i
know i assume he's dead
but he's still around and only his kids
maybe he went down the stairs
he tripped and then he became a ghost
and then he was ghost dead
i'll tell you bill cosby could do a tv
show like nobody but that guy could not
pick a [ __ ] movie script to save his
life
did you ever see ghost dog with forest
whitaker
do you remember that movie no did the
dog bump his head in the doghouse and
then become a photo oh no ghost dog
something way of the sim i don't know
what it is it was a good movie anyway
move on that went over about as well as
that guy's joke i know i know right
it's a matter that's it you know you
just
you're you're your new mom you know what
i mean like you should see how tired she
are
you're all over i'm not i'm trying to
have empathy you're tired
i thought i was up here having a good
time you're having a good time
you know i just was saying you know had
an exchange
student you sounded like an old white
lady named ethel
and literally during that whole as you
were trying to like you know
slaughter your way through that question
i was picturing that kid
like he was the one asking for advice
like what if that actually was him
who no it's not he would be like my age
and he wouldn't be dealing with that
at that age right and plus it was from
an 18 year old
that question yeah i don't know what
you're talking about
what are you talking about that one
man-to-man advice
to an 18 year old anyway
no that was a woman what
i need to talk to someone that's that's
the man-to-man advice
i thought that was a woman no it says
man to man
where did you think a woman was in there
and he said he didn't have
like a male figure in his life so he
didn't have anybody to tell him
oh i thought this was some guy hitting
on a chick i'm an idiot
what oh all right
well i still stand by it [ __ ] that guy
yes
ultimately still [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] your friends that's cause that
sounded like that whole drama sounded
like a chick situation
like i'm a god we're friends with him so
like you have to be like [ __ ] vagina
what are we doing here [ __ ] off [ __ ] all
you guys
[ __ ] all of them was that exhale
like not liking what i was doing no okay
all right i thought jeez all right
fat wife won't let me work out
there's nothing funnier than just
getting to the point
what and just being the truth i don't
even want to hear the question i just
love like the i'm going to take a
one-liner
fat life won't let me work out i love it
that's one of the greats
of all time questions hey there billy
goat
uh let's see here uh i have a problem
and would like your hilarious opinion on
what i should do
me and my wife have been together about
five years now and married for two
when we first got together i was a young
stud in my prime in shape and crushing
ass
left and right she was in good shape too
i used to work out four to five days a
week and life was great when we got
married
she didn't like me going to the gym
because she says i will leave her
for a fitness check uh the insecurity
all right
i got uh i got to the point where i had
to get her a membership so we could go
together
just so i could have my joy of pumping
iron
uh but she only went four times and
stopped going
pumping iron pump and iron you got to do
it
this guy's an old school guy pumping
iron people still say
why he was probably yeah he says it you
know
you know doesn't uh doesn't some of your
older relatives call people jive turkeys
huh i gotta watch ghost dog
[ __ ] leave my shoes on the stairs
whatever the [ __ ] that means
what does that [ __ ] mean i just love
i gotta i gotta tell you so i gotta tell
you something
as a comedian random but as a comedian i
respect the balls of an obscure
reference
she probably got offended me like what
because it's it's bill cosby we all saw
the [ __ ] movie
you think i saw every black movie that's
out there [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think she's just maybe she's really
into movies and she's [ __ ] offended
that you
think that you know that she would go
watch that pile of [ __ ]
oh my god all right so anyways now we
just wait i'm sorry just real quick
just before we move on i do find that
like white guys do have the most
random [ __ ] movie references ever
like nerdy white guys have the most rand
they're throwing it out there like
everybody knows
i do feel now do you feel like do you
feel like it's it's
isn't some of it random because maybe
they're watching really white [ __ ] that
you wouldn't watch because
i think uh because i kind of get you
know like you
every once in a while like you know some
of your your
uh your peeps will be over our house and
something will come on that i've never
heard of and you guys
go [ __ ] nuts like right it's like
frosty the snowman
every year i would watch this [ __ ] i
have no idea what it is so maybe uh
maybe there's some of that
anyways i don't want to get into that
guy's [ __ ] quagmire
huh conundrum quagmire we're using all
the uh
the big ones all right anyways now we
just had a baby now we just had a baby
girl
congratulations and we're both tired and
out of shape
i want to get back into the gym and get
rid of this dad bod
but i can't because she guilt-trips me
saying i could help with the baby
instead
uh instead of wanting to get in shape
also
she always says i'm going to get ripped
and leave her for a skinny girl in the
gym
and it annoys the [ __ ] out of me that is
annoying
yeah but you feel really insecure like
after you have a baby because it's just
your body it's like you they don't
prepare you
for what childbirth does to your body i
know but she was doing this [ __ ] before
right but she's like moving out but no
i'm not saying that she shouldn't
he should they should get a babysitter
so she can work out so they can work out
together or whatever yeah but he already
tried that and she only went four times
so now like
you know listen i've lost three friends
this year two heart attacks and a stroke
like what this guy's doing is actually
like going to prolong his life
yeah you know you don't want to have a
kid with the guy and then he drops of a
[ __ ] heart attack i mean what are we
doing here
um anyways instead of wanting to get in
shape
uh okay i read all of that
what should i do i don't want to give up
working out but i also don't want to
feel
be it i feel unsupportive as a husband
keep up the good work congrats on the
baby boy i mean
his heart's in the right place go to the
[ __ ] gym that's really hard and you
know what though
you have to go to the gym though cause
it's what you feel what
makes you feel good and like she'll get
over it
she won't take it purse just like just
have her blow you before you go to the
gym
and she can relax what that's a good no
you just give her actually
kisses and tell her she's beautiful and
tell her she's a great mom
and you'll help her out like whenever
she needs it and she'll get over it like
she's just no no take your dick down be
like do you want to hang on to this
huh you see this see this this is going
to walk right out that door
if you don't let me go to the gym
no i yeah you got it it's just sensitive
right now it's a very sensitive time so
you have to be
but she was sensitive before too yeah i
know and it might not
who knows it might be a bigger thing but
for now just like but you should still
go to the gym because you know you need
to
get your stress out and all that other
[ __ ] too so good luck with that
good luck with that all right uh
underrated arabs
oh god what no i mean
it's not bad that they're yeah i don't
know where it's going i just judged it
by
you really rated arabs well i mean hey
you know what i did ain't that bad
see that's how you heard it but that's
how you heard it
that's not how i heard it that's how i
heard it i was like oh great this would
be something complimentary considering
the beef we've been having
since 9 11. this is this is some
positive i like let's bring people
together
all right hey hey there red dildo uh i
am a 21 year old guy from saudi arabia
um wish to know if you plan to include
us in your next tour
our government pays good money for
entertainment well what are the
parameters
i just want to make sure i ain't going
over there and all of a sudden i say
something to you know
the wrong [ __ ] thing and then i get
in trouble i i don't need that
what country was i in where you
i think was singapore where i was just
going like oh [ __ ] man you know
you know you spit gum out on the street
they [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
out of you with a goddamn [ __ ]
nearest tree or something
um he says anyways in the last five
years or so i watched a considerable
amount of movies and tv shows and came
to notice that there's a stereotype
you westerners you westerns have about
us
which is that we're either illiterate
[ __ ] who live in the desert
tending our camels and thinking about
blowing your country
blowing up your country not blowing your
country or
or that we're buried in money and don't
have any problems
dude i gotta be honest with you the
second you said you were from saudi
arabia i just pictured somebody
vacationing in london
shipping his cars in one car and in one
plane and himself self in his private
jet
right yeah no there is like definitely
that stereotype of like the saudi prince
that's like yeah spending money
but i never i never thought the
illiterate thing though yeah no i never
thought that but yeah you definitely
have this idea of
yeah oh i and i have the feeling that if
i go over to the middle east
as an american that
just we just had so many [ __ ] you
know not good back and forth over there
that i'm going to get the [ __ ] ass
kicking that they want to give
our last three [ __ ] presidents um
anyway uh and i want to squash the
stereotype by saying that we live our
lives just like you
i myself come from a middle-class family
and i study energy engineering
this is such a great [ __ ] email i'm
glad this came in
i listened to western music and i'm
familiar with the bands and love the
beatles and zeppelin
i watched the nba and even like the
celtics ah this [ __ ] guy is great
the sellies my friends and i hang out in
cafes or whatever
and we try to pick up chicks
the only difference between us is that
you probably do these activities while
drinking alcohol
uh when we drink drink coffee or any
kind of soda
and that i have hair and you don't
[Laughter]
please continue consider touring here
wouldn't miss it go [ __ ] yourself well
you know what
i mean it's a nice email that is a great
email that's really cool
yeah all right that is that did make me
think
didn't we have that experience in london
not of like
saudis specifically or anything like
that but wasn't there something when we
were in london one time and there was a
bunch of cars like really
luxury cars that were just going down
this one main drive oh no it was
hilarious
those were the princes the princes were
over there what's going on
yeah yeah and they were just kind of it
was this whole
parade was like a display of beautiful
luxury vehicles that were just
okay you want to know what really
happened it was a bunch of rich
princes in in ferraris and lamborghinis
driving like in stop and go traffic just
revving the engines
they're loud as [ __ ] and they had all
these
like wraps on on the cars and [ __ ]
and i was my favorite i was walking up
the street
and as they were revving the engine like
loud as [ __ ]
this english woman just goes ah
stop it
it was hilarious the old british biddy
yeah they were showing off they
i believe i believe your people call it
stuntin
um all right now i'm in trouble
i should have said it i said it with the
next ghost dad reference
ghost dad i mean that is [ __ ] up
there hey tell everybody how great my
new hi-fi stereo is
oh it's great it's got uh highs and it's
got five oh
[ __ ] you all right god bless you all
right everybody
um well you know i would love to tour a
bunch of places if you know they'll go
once the covid cure comes i'm ready to
go i had a great set in a parking lot
tonight and i'm excited
i'm excited takes it back to the old
days man made no money
it's a bit of a hell gig i was able to
get myself through it it's fun
you got a chance to do stand up i know
you've been missing it
yeah i did i i did so all right that's
the podcast everybody uh
god bless you go [ __ ] yourselves and
i'll check in on you
on thursday